Happy Friday.
How is everyone?
Woo!
Cool.
I am excited.
We're going to keep
talking about XRD today.
We're going to pick
up where we left off.
So I filled in some numbers.
And then, we're going
to fill out this chart
and really get to a deep
understanding of XRD.
I'll also talk
about Moseley's law
and a little bit about another
type of XRD that is done.
Now, where were we?
Oh, OK.
We were here.
So on Wednesday-- and before
we fill this chart out,
I want to go back and make
sure we, kind of, get this.
Right?
We talked about the
Bragg condition.
And we talked about how the
unique thing about x-rays
is that their wavelengths
are right in that,
sort of, precious distance
regime of the spacing of atoms
in a crystal.
And so if I shine
them on the crystal,
then they can diffract.
And they can have constructive
and destructive interference,
but only if they line up.
And that's what the Bragg
diffraction tells us.
It tells us the
the Bragg condition
for when they line up.
And in particular, this
is a pretty nice image.
So you can see here's
one x-ray coming in.
And it's a wave.
It's a wave.
So it's going to be a
wave that goes like that,
and then it bounces
off of this surface.
Now a second one doesn't
bounce off that top surface.
It bounces off of
the one beneath it.
OK?
And they're separated
by a distance D.
So this could be
any set of planes.
Right?
So here are my planes now.
So these black
atoms are one plane.
Right?
But these yellow
ones are another one.
That's another plane
that you could see.
Remember, one of the assumptions
of the Bragg condition
is that these planes
are like mirrors.
So we lose a sense of where
the atoms are exactly,
and we just write
a mirror there.
And we say it's
reflecting off the mirror.
So where's the next one?
And you can take
the orange ones.
That's another plane.
The red ones and so forth.
Now you have a wave on top.
OK?
You've got a wave on top.
And then, you got a wave coming
down and bouncing off the one
beneath it and for those
to constructively interfere
so that you pick up a
signal in the detector.
There's only one way
for that to happen.
And that's if this
distance plus that distance
is equal to a multiple
of the wavelength.
Right?
And that is the Bragg condition.
It has to come all the way
down to here, which makes
that theta equal to that theta.
You see that?
Because they've gone up to
this point, up to that line.
They've gone the same distance.
So they're waving together.
All right?
And it's that point
where now this
is the extra that the
one that bounces off
of this plane, that's the
extra distance it goes.
That's the Bragg condition.
OK?
And remember, in this class,
OK, so it could be any multiple.
But here, we're just
going to assume n equals 1
because it's the easiest case.
OK, good.
That's the Bragg condition.
Then, we did
something beyond just
that because that tells
us what the wavelength has
to be to get a spot,
to get something
the detector can see because
it constructively interferes.
Everything else is destructive.
No signal.
But we did one more thing.
We also said that d
for some set of planes.
Remember, this HKL is
just telling me which
one of these I'm talking about.
That's what HKL is.
I'm going to pick
one of these planes.
And the distance
between them is DHKL.
OK, good.
But we know from before,
from our Miller times,
we know that that is equal to
the square root of a squared
plus k squared plus l
squared for the [INAUDIBLE]
we're talking about.
All right?
So you see, it's kind
of Bragg plus Miller.
Bragg plus distance Miller.
Right?
Miller cubic.
That's what we're
really combining here.
The distance given
by this formula
when we talk about Miller
planes, that combined
gave us this.
Lambda over 2a
squared equals sine
squared theta HKL over h squared
plus k squared plus elsewhere.
And all I've done is
substitute and square.
OK?
And we did one more
thing on Wednesday.
And we talked about constance.
And we said, well, if something
is equal to a constant,
then it's a constant.
All right?
That's some good math.
And so we said, well,
that's the whole beauty
of these characteristic
x-rays because if you
take a k alpha line from copper,
it's always 1.54 angstroms.
It's always lambda equals 1.54.
That's what's so nice about it.
Doesn't depend on anything else.
Just the metal you put
in there is the target.
It's called a target
because you're
targeting it with electrons.
So the copper target, k
alpha, lambda constant.
Lattice constant?
That's built into the name.
Constant.
Constant equals the angle and
the plane it's reflecting off.
And so our job then in
crystallography and doing
x-ray diffraction, our
job is to figure out how
to keep this thing a constant.
The same constant.
All right?
That's what constant means.
OK?
That's our job.
And that's where we left off.
And we say, OK, well let's
take this to the next level.
Let's do an actual experiment.
Now how do you do experiments?
Well you have equipment.
And this is what a really
cool XRD machine looks like.
This is what happens when
you don't have any money.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is what's in my lab.
It's true.
You can come see it.
But you see, the point is
they knew the same thing.
We don't need fancy
equipment at MIT.
No, it's the ideas
that matter that you're
putting into this thing.
But that's kind of cool still.
I like the way that looks.
Same thing.
Right?
Source.
Sample.
Detector.
That's hard to see.
But source, sample,
detector from the 60s-ish.
OK.
[LAUGHING]
All right.
So now it's easier.
Of course, you can understand.
I mean, some of these
things have different ways
of doing it.
But you can understand changing
the angle is going to be easier
to move that sample.
Right?
And then, maybe
the detector moves.
But you might keep the
source x-rays fixed.
And what happens?
Well, you do this, and
you generate a spectrum.
So you're changing the angle.
You're keeping this fixed.
And you're saying,
what do I got?
Well here, in this case,
I'm telling you what I got.
I got aluminum.
I put aluminum in there.
And I shot x-rays.
If anybody gives
you an XRD pattern,
they got to tell you what
kind of x-rays they used.
Right?
That's really important.
At some point, you
got to know this.
This is pretty important.
The lambda is from
a copper target,
and the k alpha lines
is 1.54 angstroms.
And this is the spectrum.
And I'm being asked to get the
crystal structure of aluminum
and the lattice constant.
And I can get that
because, look,
I can simply read off peaks.
And those are the
peaks, and I've kind of
highlighted them there.
2 theta.
More for historical reasons,
you take 2 theta measurements,
even though, in the Bragg
condition, it's just theta.
OK, we can divide by 2.
Right?
And so here are
those first 4 peaks.
And I've just listed them here.
Peak 1, 2, 3, 4.
Sin squared of half of that.
Gesundheit.
OK, there it is.
And then, we have our recipe.
I gave you this recipe as a
way to keep this constant.
All right?
It's an easier way to do it if
you scale and clear fractions.
It's just easier.
So that's why I've
given you that recipe.
So let's do it.
So first we normalize.
What does that mean?
Well, you have the smallest
value of science course data.
I'm just going to divide
everything by that.
OK?
So that's where we left off.
One because that's what
I'm normalizing by.
And then, this
one would be 1.33.
And this one would be 2.67.
And this one would be 3.67.
And so that's good.
But I don't want fractions.
It's going to be
easier for me to think
about this as integers.
And so we clear fractions.
What does clear fractions mean?
That!
Clear the fractions.
Get rid of them.
Make it integers.
How do you do that?
Find what you multiply this by
so that they're all integers.
OK, I got an idea.
How about 3 times 3.
In this case, times 3 equals 3.
OK, good.
And in this case,
well, I don't mean--
OK, anyway, times 3 equals 4.
Times 3.
Don't multiply it by
a different number.
I'm clearing the fractions
for the whole table.
I'm multiplying by
the same number.
OK, good.
8.
And this is times 3 equals 11.
So I've got 3, 4, 8, 11.
And that's what I
need to work with.
That's what I need to work
with because now, you see,
it's now--
I hope it's kind of starting
to make some sense--
if I can get this
to be 8 squared
plus k squared plus l squared,
well then I've done my job.
I've kept this constant.
That's the trick.
Right?
I've done my job.
I've just made the math easy.
If I can get h squared
plus k squared plus l
squared to equal these things,
then I'm keeping it constant.
So let's see.
What would that be?
So this has to be h squared--
let me just write here--
plus k squared plus l squared.
OK?
I want those to be
an h squared plus k.
So if I do that, well, this
looks a whole lot like 1 1 1.
That works.
And for 4, 2 0 0.
OK, and for 8, 2 2 0.
And finally, for 11, 3 1 1.
Aw, it's a beautiful thing.
I've gone from angles to planes.
These are planes.
H, k and l mean one of these.
It means one of those.
That's what it means,
a set of those.
And I have found now, literally,
which ones give me each peak.
This peak is the 1 1 1 plain.
It's x-rays bouncing
off of that,
reflecting off of that,
and the one below it,
and the one below
it, and seeing where
it gives you constructive
interference,
and gives you the
Bragg condition.
And therefore, a peak.
OK.
All right.
Now hold on.
Hold on.
Now, OK, have we determined
the crystal structure?
Have we determined
Can anybody?
How do we get the crystal
structure from this,
from these peaks?
How do we get?
Well, let's see.
OK.
Let's see.
Could it be bcc?
What else did we
learn on Wednesday?
Right?
What else did we
learn on Wednesday?
We learned about
selection rules.
You got to remember
the selection rules.
Those factor in.
So let's write those down here.
Let's remind ourselves
of, OK, that's important.
Right?
Now I mentioned how
this came about.
I don't need you to know how
to derive the selection rules.
But I did talk about
why they come about
because, for some
of these cuts, you
could have a plane
in between that
destroys the signal, depending
on which crystal structure it
is and which plane
you're talking about.
And when it comes down to
it, for a simple cubic,
it's anything goes.
Anything.
Oh, polonium.
And for bcc, it adds
to an even number.
And for FCC, no mixing.
No mixing of odd and even.
Those are the selection rules.
You don't need to know
how to divide them,
but I do want you to
know what they are.
So now we can see,
well OK, hold on.
If this were a bcc crystal
and they had to add to even 1
plus 1 plus 1 is 3.
Bam!
It's not bcc.
Right?
Yeah?
OK.
Yeah, but now, hang on.
If it's no mixing on even,
did I handle that one OK?
Yeah!
Odd!
Even!
Even.
Odd.
This looks like an
FCC crystal to me.
Right?
This looks like an FCC crystal.
And I can go even further.
I can calculate the
lattice constant.
I can calculate the lattice
constant cause it's right here.
It's right here.
Right?
So that's the lattice constant.
That's a number that's
a constant lambda.
So I could take any one of
those planes, any one of those,
any one of these four peaks.
And if I did this
right, they better
give me the same
lattice constant.
And that's actually the
last step in the recipe.
Did I put the recipe?
Yes!
All right.
This is the recipe I gave
you on Wednesday for you
all to become crystallographers.
X-ray defractioners.
That's OK.
We'll make it work.
You're X-ray diffractioners.
And the thing is, you got to
remember how powerful this is.
Yeah, how powerful
this is because we've
learned about perfect crystals.
And now, we've just gotten
the single most important way
to figure out which one we have.
We shine x-rays on it, and we
look for diffraction peaks.
That's it.
This is a very powerful tool.
And it is used all over the
place in materials chemistry,
physics.
You name the field,
x-ray diffraction
is a starting point for
characterizing the crystal.
And so, the last
sanity check that you
want to do here because it'll
help you make sure you did
these points correctly,
is compute these values
because, you know, this is it.
Right?
Sine squared over a squared
plus k squared plus l
squared better be a constant.
If it's not, then
you've done something
wrong in this analysis.
Right?
You could just calculate the
lattice constant for each peak,
and they also better agree.
So I won't do that, but it
turns out we did it right.
For each one of these,
that is indeed a constant.
We have achieved our goal.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
How you use XRD.
Well, let's see.
Let's use it to figure out
what phase of material we have.
Why does this matter, right?
Well I have a why this matters,
but there's multiple reasons
for why this matters.
As I think we've talked about,
the properties of a material
depend on the chemistry
in the material,
but they also depend on the
structure of the material.
And we're making solids, so
those structures are crystals,
until next week when we destroy
the crystals by putting defects
in them!
But for now, they're
these perfect crystals.
And they have this, kind
of, repeating pattern.
Worry about hcp.
bcc, ah we're comfortable.
fcc, comfortable. bcc.
Now, this is called
a phase diagram.
This is called a phase diagram.
Phase diagrams will be
on the quiz next week.
I'm kidding.
They're not going
to be on the quiz
because this isn't a class
about phase diagrams.
But I want you to know
what a phase diagram is.
It is a map of materials.
It is like a treasure
map, literally
because you find I need iron
to have a different property.
Oh!
If I go to this pressure
and that temperature, aha!
It can have a
different property.
Why?
Because it has a different
crystal structure.
So the crystal
structure of something--
in this case, it's iron--
depends on the pressure
and temperature.
And the properties depend
on the crystal structure.
So we've got a way now
to change materials.
Same element.
I'm just changing its structure.
I love this one.
This is water.
Now don't worry about
how complex this is.
Actually, the whole
point is it's complex.
This is the phase
diagram of water.
Now this doesn't
even have them all.
There are 17 current
phases of ice.
17 different crystalline
structures of ice.
That is incredible.
Right?
You can actually imagine
why, from your knowledge
in this class already,
those are hydrogen bonds.
They're kind of strong,
but they're not too strong.
There's a lot of ways
that those water molecules
could form a solid.
And they do.
17 to date and counting.
Let's see.
And this tells you
which one you have.
Now Earth's operating conditions
are right around here.
And that's a really
good thing because there
is a liquid phase in there.
Ice 1 is here. ih is ice one.
And it's a really good
thing because of the fish
because if you weren't ice
1, then when it freezes,
it wouldn't have a
different density.
And the ice wouldn't
float to the top.
And the fish could still live,
which they do in the winter
because you don't
freeze from the bottom.
You freeze from the top.
That's because it's
ice 1 and not ice 8.
It would be terrible.
But yet, we know about these.
And how do we know?
We know because of
crystallography.
We know because of XRD.
We can figure out.
Now if you're out and
maybe it's a Friday night,
so maybe this is a good idea--
it's a good time to mention
it--
you might get ice in your
water out at a restaurant.
How do you know which
kind of ice it is?
Talk about XRD.
It's the only real way to
figure out which one of these
you really have.
OK.
So for example,
if I were to think
of other types of
problems you might get,
well, here's a good one.
OK, here's a good one.
So this is an X-ray
diffraction spectrum.
And I give it to you, and I
don't even tell you what it is.
Why is that?
Here's a pattern that I
put something in there,
and I measure these pics.
And I tell you the source.
It's the k alpha line of copper.
So that's the wavelength
of the source.
First thing is what
lattice, what symmetry,
does this correspond to?
Is it simple cubic,
body centered
cubic, or face centered cubic?
Can we get that?
We could get that because
of the exact same thing
that we just talked about.
Right?
This can not be.
If it were simple cubic,
you'd see the peaks.
Mm!
But know that some
peaks are forbidden,
so they don't show up.
Right?
And you only get peaks
that look like an FCC,
according to our
selection rules.
No mixing odd even at work.
So this is an FCC crystal.
So I've already learned that.
And then to say,
well, what's the--
OK, use the 1 1 1 peak to
calculate the lattice constant.
OK.
Well, we can do that.
Right?
So the 1 1 1 peak is
even labeled there.
It's 38 degrees.
38 degrees.
So to theta is 38 degrees.
So that means that theta--
OK, I can do this
one-- is 19 degrees.
OK.
Oh, oh, oh, from Bragg.
Lambda equals to d sine theta.
But look, label,
label the plane.
This corresponds to a plane.
So some distance
between some planes
corresponds to some
angle that gave me
constructive interference
for those planes.
Let's pass it around so you
guys can look at these planes.
They're beautiful things.
Now that means that if I
look at the first peek,
I know what la-- well
I labeled them here.
In the last one, I didn't.
And you want to find those.
Here, I'm giving you the planes.
So if I do that, then
d 1 1 1 equals lambda
over 2 sine theta 1 1 1,
which equals 2.37 angstroms.
OK.
Have I answered the question?
I haven't answered the
question yet because, you see,
the question says what's
the lattice constant.
But I'm very close.
The lattice constant is
related because of Miller.
The Miller plains
equation for lattice.
Lattice constant.
Distance between any planes.
Oh, this is all just
coming together.
And so d 1 1 1 is
equal to a over 3.
And so a equals 4.1 angstroms.
Oh, you could go even further.
You could figure out, now
that you know it's fcc--
it's a single atom
base, it's fcc crystal,
you could actually figure
out the atomic radius.
I got a, and I know the
close pack direction.
Right?
I could actually figure
out the atomic radius.
And I could go into
my periodic table
and figure out what I have
just from the atomic radii
listed in the periodic table
and the crystal structures.
FCC.
Automic radius.
Which one is it?
It's gold.
So this is the kind of
thing that you guys now
have the power to do.
You have the power to do this.
You can go back
and forth between--
based on your
knowledge of crystals
and now your knowledge of
x-rays and how x-rays interact
with crystals you can do this.
Oh, that went too far.
OK, so now I'm going to get
to the why this matters.
So there's two different
sources, two different targets.
Remember, we can call
them sources or targets.
And notice they both have
this continuous radiation.
And I will talk about that.
The [INAUDIBLE] will
end with a discussion
a little bit on what
you can do with that.
But for now, let's keep
focused on these lines,
these discrete
characteristic lines.
So there's the k
alpha from molybdenum.
There's the k alpha for copper.
OK, now Moseley, Henry Moseley,
was a brilliant scientist.
And he was working with
Rutherford and others.
And he was really interested
in looking at the trends.
So he took all of
these elements.
So from calcium all
the way to zinc.
20 to 30.
And he said I want
to look at the k
alpha lines of all of these.
I want to look at the K
And what he found
was extraordinary.
He did more.
38 in total.
But I'm just going to show
you his data for these.
OK?
And what he did was absolutely
profound because what
he noticed--
there are the lines.
These are actually
his measurements.
OK?
These are his k alpha lines.
And what he noticed in
going from calcium down to--
ohh-- brass?
OK, we'll talk about
that in a minute.
It's supposed to
be zinc, isn't it?
Why is it zinc?
Well, why is it not zinc?
Let's think about that later.
For now he noticed that this
has a square root relationship
to the energy.
So Moseley came up with--
he was working on this in 1912.
OK?
You got to remember 1913.
1912 was when Rutherford did
the gold foil experiments.
It had been 44 years
since Mendeleev
put his periodic table to
paper and published that.
So for 44 years, we
had a periodic table.
But see, the thing is,
there was a huge problem
with the periodic
table because Mendeleev
had this, sort of, brilliant
realization that periodicity--
periodicity-- was related
to, both, the atomic mass--
and remember, we
talked about this--
and the properties, the
chemical properties.
That chemical properties.
That allowed him to create
in ordering of the elements.
In ordering of the elements.
That is still the
ordering, essentially,
that we have today.
But the problem is why did
they have that ordering?
I didn't really tell you why,
sometimes, he was like, well,
the properties win.
OK, maybe the mass-- no, no.
Properties win.
Properties need to be
aligned in this column,
so I'm I'm going
to move those over.
Like, that's what he did.
But he didn't know why, except
that it made sense to him.
Moseley's experiments told us.
They gave us the why.
Aw, it was so important.
And Moseley's law--
Moseley's law--
was, essentially,
him thinking about
the Bohr model
for these characteristic x-rays.
So he said that h nu--
so that's the frequency
for some k alpha line--
is equal to 13.6 ev.
All that looks familiar.
Times z minus 1 squared.
And then, he did the
difference in energy,
just like we've done now a
number of times in this class.
That's what he did.
And this is 3/4.
Why this?
Well, let's talk about
that in a second.
So 13.6 ev times 3/4
times z minus 1 squared.
Two things about this, right?
One is why is it 1 over 1
squared minus 1 over 2 squared?
Well that's because they
knew, or at least they
were pretty confident, that
you had this positive charge
in the middle here.
That's the protons
and the nucleus.
And then, you had
these electrons.
Right?
So you had, like,
the 1s electrons.
And then, you had
another shell out here.
And so they knew, OK, 2s.
Maybe that's combined
with 2p, so it goes on.
So what happens in
the x-ray experiment?
Well what happens is you
shoot an electron in.
Rank and just crank
the voltage up
so high that an electron
could come and knock that out.
Right?
And so that's what did it.
And so now one of these
can cascade down there
and give off a k alpha photon.
Right?
This is nothing new.
We've talked about this.
But you see it here
in the equation.
You see it in two ways.
First, we're going from 2 to 1.
1 squared minus 1/2 squared.
3/4.
Right?
But second-- and
this was critical--
the z minus.
The z minus told us that
all these positive charges
in here, all these
positive charges,
are screened perfectly by
one electron, this one that
was left.
And it works.
He assumed perfect [INAUDIBLE].
So what do all these see?
They see z minus 1.
They see z minus 1 if z is
related to the atomic number.
Now here's where
this was so powerful
because when you-- and
if you can't read this,
don't worry about that.
I just want to show you that it
is a perfectly straight line.
When you plot the K
alpha transitions,
these are different elements.
These are his
different elements.
And if you plot the square
root of the frequency
versus element, it is a
perfect line that holds.
And so what Moseley
wrote in the paper
is we have your proof in 1930
that there is, in the atom,
a fundamental quantity.
A fundamental quantity, which
increases by regular steps
as one passes from one
element to the next.
This quantity can
only be-- only be--
the charge on the
central positive nucleus,
of the existence of which we
already have definite proof.
Now we know about that.
We know from experiments
that Rutherford
did that that nucleus
had the positive charge.
But they didn't know
that it was connected
to the position in
the periodic table.
In fact, years later,
people talking about those
experiences--
I mean, people didn't even
take Rutherford's experiments
as seriously until
Moseley's work came along.
44 years had come
since Mendeleev.
But Moseley gave it the
foundation that it needed.
Periodicity is because
of atomic number.
Periodicity is atomic number.
That was not known.
That z gives you
the periodicity.
Right?
And that gives you, also,
the number of protons.
This was a time when they
didn't know what was going on.
Why did the mass change so much
the neutron wasn't discovered
till 1932, 20 years later?
But this gave the
grounding that was
needed to the chemistry
of the periodic table.
It was a very
important discovery.
Very, very important discovery.
So that's my why this matters.
And it's really tragic
because he died, tragically,
in World War I at age 27.
And the Nobel Prize
was not given in 1916
for either physics or chemistry.
He died in 1915.
And most people, at the
time, believe that he
would have won it at age 28.
That's how important
that discovery was.
OK, let's go back to brass.
I got to go to brass.
What's going on here?
What is going on with brass?
Right?
Any ideas?
Why didn't he just
put zinc there?
It looked so good until brass!
What is going on?
Well, ha, here, I'll
give you a hint.
OK, the melting temperature.
Let's see.
Ah, brass.
OK, zinc melts
around 420 C. Brass,
which equals zinc and copper,
melts at around 900 C or more.
Greater than 900 C.
That's a hint because if
we go back to the video--
let's go back.
Oh, the sound is on.
Those are the electrons!
A small portion of the time.
Let me set that up because
I'm doing in the middle.
The electrons are
coming off of a cathode
because Rankin has cranked
the voltage way up,
and pumped all the air out.
So those electrons
are coming off
with thousands and
thousands of KEV.
OK?
They're coming out.
And that's what's
on the right here.
There they are.
The cathode is shaped
to focus the electrons
onto a small portion
of the target, which
increases the intensity
of the x-rays produced.
The target is,
typically, a piece
of tungsten or
molybdenum, which may
be embedded in a stationary
water or oil coiled rod,
or on a rotating disk.
The high speed electrons
collide with the target
and rapidly lose energy.
There are two x-ray
producing interactions
between the incident
electrons and the atom.
Ah!
Look at the power!
You can feel the power coming
into that tiny little piece
of metal.
Now some of the time,
you get the transition
that we talked about.
You knock an electron out,
and you emit a photon--
a k alpha photon--
or maybe an l beta photon.
Right?
And sometimes you
slow the electron down
so you get the Brahms fraulein.
But there's so much energy
being pumped into this material.
And a lot of times, those
electrons just collide and heat
up the metal.
That metal is getting
extremely hot.
And in these experiments,
either you cooled it,
or you might rotate it quickly
so that it gets to cool down.
It gets a little break.
Or you do both.
Or you just throw up
your hands and you say,
you know what, I'm just
going to go for an aloy
that's got some zinc in it,
but won't melt every time.
Yeah, that was a good idea.
So you put brass in, OK, you're
going to get the copper lines.
But you'll get the zinc lines.
You'll get the zinc lines.
And that was why he used brass.
And that's why you can
see you get extra lines
in the case of brass.
Al right.
Good!
All right.
Now I am very excited
about Moseley.
You know, it allowed us to
actually understand this
not just because.
Look at this.
Mendeleev was like, you
know what, cobalt and nickel
can't be swapped.
Hey, all you people who
just think about mass,
you're not going to put
them in the order you think.
I'm changing that.
I'm changing it because
properties matter.
Moseley said, no,
you're changing it
because it's the right order
because of the blue numbers.
You're changing it because
there is an actual count here
that matters.
And that is why your
periodic table is what it is.
Absolutely critical.
It put the lantinides
in the right place.
It allowed the
prediction of elements--
like [INAUDIBLE] and a number
of others that hadn't been
discovered yet--
and it set it all on this
much more solid grounding.
So that is the
contribution of Moseley.
I can't help it!
I'm very excited so
I brought t-shirts.
I knew I was talking
about Moseley.
Now--
Woo!
I'm going.
OK.
All right.
There.
And in the middle.
And over there.
[CHEERING]
This way!
And, oh!
That's a bad arm.
[CHEERING]
And up there.
Hold on.
Hold on now.
OK, there.
There.
And this is all for Moseley.
Ah!
This is all for Mosley!
[CHEERING]
All right.
Now, OK.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Now apart from me showing off--
I don't have much of an arm--
one thing I'd like to say is, if
you did already get a t-shirt,
please, just hand it off
to a friend or somebody.
You know, let's share.
Sharing is always caring.
Now here's another type of
x-ray I want to talk about.
And z, actually, this
is much less used today.
I hope you've gotten
a sense of how
powerful these
characteristic x-rays are.
You know exactly what
the wavelength is.
But in the very earliest
XRD experiments,
it was the Bremsstrahlung
radiation that was used.
And that was by Van Laway.
So I want to just
tell you about that.
And so here's an
example of an Mo target.
Now let's remind ourselves
what we're looking at.
These are x-rays.
These are x-ray intensities
versus wavelength.
And this corresponds
as 5, 10, 15, 20.
That corresponds
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
Electrons.
That's thousands of electron
volts of the incoming electron.
That electron that came in
here and knocked this out
from the cathode.
Right?
OK.
Now that electron--
if it comes in,
and we talked
about this already,
but let me remind you-- if
it comes in at, kind of,
a low energy, well,
you're still going
to get this continuous spectrum.
This continuous spectrum.
Oh!
Why does it look like that?
Beyond the scope of
what we need to know.
But in case you're
wondering, it has
to do with very
complicated effects that
happen when x-rays come
off and then are reabsorbed
by the same material.
You can imagine
that that could lead
to all sorts of interesting
cascades of absorption
and emission.
That's what leads to this shape.
But we don't need to
know those details.
What we need to know
is that as you increase
the power of those
incident electrons,
you're going to get more and
more intensity of x-rays.
And this goes down.
The minimum wavelength
or maximum energy
of the continuous spectrum--
the maximum energy goes up
because the maximum energy
you can get in the
continuous spectrum
is equal to the incident
electron itself.
So it's set.
Right?
Remember the Duane
something limit?
Duane Hunt?
OK, we talked about that
already, how to get that value.
Yeah, but then you get
to this certain point!
And look, all of a sudden, the
characteristic lines appear.
And those are the K alpha
lines for molybdenum.
Why all of a sudden?
Well because you
got over the amount
of energy needed to kick out
a 1s electron from molybdenum.
That's exactly why.
Before that, you
had enough energy
to produce x-rays,
but not enough
to kick out the 1s electron.
It's kicking out
the 1s electron that
gives you characteristic peaks.
OK, good.
This is all reminder
stuff, but I
want to get back on that page.
But see now, OK, this
continuous part is also used.
And it was used, like
I said, by Von Laue.
And Von Laue was, again, a
really, really smart cookie.
And he used the Bragg
condition to prove
that the x-rays and the space
light of structure of crystals
can be interfered with each
other to make this diffraction.
But what he did was different.
OK, so the Nobel Prize was
given for this epoch making
discovery.
And I'm actually very happy that
the people that worked with him
also shared the Nobel Prize.
Walter and Paul.
What they did was
different though.
They took this
continuous spectrum.
And instead of fixing the
angle and the lambda--
I'm sorry, instead
of varying the angle
but having a fixed lambda,
they did the opposite
because the continuous
spectrum has all lambdas.
Right?
And so you can imagine
how this works.
Right?
You can imagine how this works.
So in the Laue
version of XRD, you
shoot the x-rays, which have
all the wavelengths in them,
at a crystal that's fixed.
I'm not changing the angle.
OK?
And what you get are
still diffraction peaks.
You get spots.
So In Laue XRD, you
have a single crystal.
It's got to be the same
everywhere, in this case.
You have a single crystal.
Theta is fixed.
You don't move it around.
But lambda varies continuously.
OK.
And the pattern that you
get reflects the symmetry.
Pattern reflects the
crystal symmetry.
How is that possible?
Well, you can actually see
this by thinking about the--
do I have another picture?
I just have his one.
You can see this by thinking
about that model, which is
somewhere out there in the sea.
Where is the model?
I don't see it.
Ah!
All the way in the
back waving around.
Let's see if I can draw this.
Let's see.
Ah, I'm not going to try.
If I shoot x-rays that
have a fixed lambda in,
but I vary the angle, then
as we've been talking about,
there's going to be
certain angles where you
get constructive interference.
Now if I keep the
thing fixed and I
shoot all lambdas into it, well,
take a look at the crystal.
Imagine that I'm holding
that structure right now.
OK?
Well I'm going to see
this set of planes here.
So I'm to see this
set of planes.
Maybe they're
[INAUDIBLE] planes.
I don't know.
Right?
And I'm going to
bounce off of that
and constructively
interfere, maybe,
if I've got the right lambda.
But see, if I'm looking at
the crystal and it's fixed,
I'm going to see also
there's another set of planes
like that.
Do you see?
There's another set
of planes like that.
And if I'm a different
wavelength-- not the same one,
but a different one--
I might constructively
interfere with those.
But you can see that the angle
that I make will be different.
And so I'll put a spot
in a different place.
You see?
So I've got all the
wavelengths there.
And as they constructively
interfere with different planes
that they see, they
make different spots.
They make different spots.
And that's what those are.
In those spots, it's more
complicated to get crystal
structure from those spots.
It's more complicated.
You can get symmetry
fairly easily.
But getting the structure
itself is a little bit more
complicated.
It can be tricky.
And for that, another
reason most work today
is done with
characteristic peaks, XRD.
But this happened before.
And so I wanted
to show it to you.
And this resolved,
actually, in one
of Laue's very famous papers.
It resolved the structure
of zinc sulfide.
It was very important work.
And those are the spots.
Look at that pattern there.
See, the thing that you
could get is the symmetry.
Oh, by the way, by the way, I'm
not going to test you on Laue.
I'm only talking about
it for five minutes here.
So in this class,
I want you to know
about using
characteristic peaks,
and all the things we've
been talking about.
Laue is just on the
side for knowledge.
We won't test on this.
But I want to end by
telling you a story.
This tells you something
about crystal symmetry.
What is symmetry?
Well it just means, if I
rotate it, is it the same?
Or if I translate
it, is it the same?
Give me just one minute
because this is actually
a really interesting story.
That's translational symmetry.
We looked at this
picture already.
There's no rotational symmetry.
To get back to this picture, I'd
have to rotate the whole thing
by 360 degrees.
But see, there are
crystals that actually
have only rotational symmetry
and no translational symmetry.
And Dan Shechtman
was the one who
discovered these in the 1980s.
Nobody believed him.
His advisor told him to
go back and read the book.
And you know who wrote the book?
Linus Pauling.
Linus Pauling wrote the
book on chemical bonds.
Literally, the book was
called The Chemical Bond.
And Linus Pauling took the lead.
He won two Nobel
prizes, not one.
He took the lead in
attacking Shechtman.
Shechtman had discovered
quasi crystals.
quasi crystals, but nobody--
he was fired his papers.
His papers weren't published.
And for 10 years,
nobody believed him.
Linus Pauling said
famously, "There
are no such things as
quasi crystals, only
quasi scientists."
That's how bad it was.
Oh!
But Shechtman had his day.
He won the Nobel Prize.
And he had his day.
And he was proven right.
And these quasi crystals
are absolutely fascinating.
Rotational, but no
translational symmetry.
Have a great weekend!